après des mois d'incertitude sur le
déroulement des manifestations pour
commémorer la révolution française le
restant président de la mission du
bicentenaire jean-noël janet a enfin pu
annoncer aujourd'hui le programme des
festivités et honig monnaie
d'entrée de jeu jean noël jeanneney
annonce la couleur tant sur le retard
qu'ils étaient pris dans l'organisation
du bicentenaire avant sa nomination que
sur les grands axes et les objectifs qui
ont guidé ses choix
chacun sait qu'un grand retard avait été
écrit je n'épiloguerai pas là dessus
j'ai eu 24 heures pour angers mire et
ensuite il nous est revenu d'agir quels
principes mettons nous en avons fait les
ramasser en quelques phrases d'abord la
révolution appartient au monde entier
nous ne ferons pas une
commémoration franco centriste nous ne
serons pas du col qui n'est pas question
de rab ouvrir là l'héritage de le
refermer de le réduire sur je ne sais
quel plus petit commun dénominateur d'un
consensus supposé de l'ampleur donc sur
tous les plans ce calendrier du
bicentenaire avec dès la nuit du 1er
janvier 89 des montgolfières dans tous
les départements le 21 mars 1er germinal
et jour du printemps les maires les
écoliers planteront large de la liberté
dans leur commune le saint clair ce sera
la reconstitution des états généraux à
versailles puis les fêtes de la
fraternité à la fin de juin qui nous
mèneront à la grande célébration quatre
jours de fête nationale dont une soirée
jean michel jarre du 13 au 16 juillet et
la présence de nombreux chefs d'état
enfin le 26 août ce sera l'hommage du
monde entier à la déclaration des droits
de l'homme
un grand moment sur le